[Music]
we are now entering a new era where it
is possible to live younger longer all
while achieving the financial freedom of
our dreams
powering this movement are legions of
ambitious self-starters who believe in
doing well and doing good at the same
time
this new lifestyle system may change
everything about how we engage in our
health and prosperity but it all started
simply with an inquisitive young man
living on a farm
dr joel wallock was born into farm
living in rural missouri where he tended
to vegetable crops and livestock with
equal care as he worked on his high
school studies and on becoming an eagle
scout dr wallach gravitated towards
animal science plant science soil
science and veterinary medicine to learn
more dr wallach got a summer job at the
st louis zoo
where he had the privilege of caring for
exotic animals alongside marlon perkins
of mutual of omaha's wild kingdom fame
inspired by mr perkins dr wallach found
his mission early in life
to protect the welfare of animals plants
and the earth itself
he wanted all living things to thrive
and prosper back on the family farm dr
wallach had an epiphany that would
advance his new mission for decades to
come
he realized that livestock received
better nutrition than humans
dr wallach observed that nutrient-dense
alfalfa pellets fed to livestock were a
cost-effective gold standard practice
for preventing infertility birth defects
heart disease arthritis and other
degenerative diseases
but he wondered
why is it common practice for livestock
to get this nutrition but not humans as
dr wallach went to the university of
missouri to study agriculture and
veterinary medicine he was determined to
solve this nutritional mystery
in organic chemistry class dr wallach
had another breakthrough when he learned
that minerals are needed for hundreds of
life-sustaining reactions in the body
with his agricultural background dr
wallach also knew that these same
minerals are often lacking in the soil
and in our diet dr wallach knew he was
on to something significant
after receiving his bachelor of science
in agriculture in 1962 and his doctorate
in veterinary medicine in 1964
he began chasing the answers that he
knew would bring vibrant health and
wellness to all living creatures on
earth
he studied nutritional deficiency
diseases he began working as a
veterinary pathology assistant
conducting up to 25 animal autopsies
daily he investigated the mineral intake
of the world's longest living cultures
he traveled to africa to treat and save
exotic animals and endangered species
in 1966 he was invited by marlon perkins
to participate in a 7.5 million dollar
national institutes of health study on
ecology environment pollution and plant
and animal health
the massive study became dr wallach's
focus for the next 12 years over time dr
wallach performed thousands of animal
autopsies across 454 species
including 3 000 humans
his work was included in 70
peer-reviewed journal articles and 15
textbook chapters
[Music]
dr wallach also began working on his own
textbook the diseases of exotic animals
the medical and surgical management
which is now recommended by the
smithsonian institute as a foundation
text for all zoos
dr wallach's discoveries from this
prolific time are still used today to
reduce degenerative disease
improve fertility and extend longevity
for exotic animals and livestock but
most significantly after thousands of
animal and human autopsies dr wallach
gained unprecedented insight on the
inner workings of the earth's
inhabitants what he discovered was a
near universal trend
across species minerals were the
currency of life itself
soon after this revelation dr wallach
identified the first non-human case of
cystic fibrosis in a rhesus monkey
he named selenium deficiency as the
cause
challenging the established belief that
the disease was genetic in nature dr
wallach's findings were met with
resistance as the nih and media alike
tried to silence his discovery and
discredit his qualifications knowing
that his discoveries could help millions
of people if he had additional
qualifications at age 40 dr wallick
decided to become a naturopathic doctor
after receiving his nd dr wallach
started a practice and began adapting
his veterinary nutritional formulas for
human use
these formulations such as his liquid
mineral toddy worked so well that his
patients told everyone they knew
soon his clinic was seeing 50 people
daily with his clinic's capacity maxed
out dr wallock realized he needed a
better system that would enable him to
help more people information was the
answer
by teaching others how to achieve and
share vibrant health he could remove all
limitations and help millions of people
dr wallach created an educational health
seminar called dead doctors don't lie
the tape of his seminars resonated so
powerfully with americans that it sold
over a hundred and fifty million copies
without the benefit of social media
with dead doctors don't lie dr wallach
finally had a way to go directly to the
public with his own information on
nutrition
information he knew could dramatically
improve their health but dr wallach's
next breakthrough was the real game
changer enabling newly healthy people to
achieve amazing quality of life
all by helping others
[Music]